think we all know where this is going
let's be honest it's pride month and
there are so many people to be proud of
this year including all the stars that
have come out here's a look at this
year's newest celebrity members to the
lgbtq plus community
rebel wilson recently introduced the
world to her girlfriend ramona aguma via
instagram with a pitch perfect caption
that read
i thought i was searching for a disney
prince but maybe what i really needed
all this time was a disney princess
hashtag love is love
ah however rebels coming out sadly was
not on her own terms as it was revealed
that she was given only
two days to comment on her new
relationship
due to a story set to be published in
the sydney morning herald
rebel acknowledged the situation by
responding to a fan via twitter who
condemned the outlet's actions tweeting
it was a very hard situation but trying
to handle it with grace
christelle stouse might be selling
sunset but after releasing this video
she sold fans on her authentic self it's
coming along
okay
i'm gonna come out of it now season five
of the hit reality show touched on
chrishell's public breakup with her
ex-boyfriend and boss jason oppenheim
but in the reunion chrishell flipped the
script getting candid about her new
relationship with rapper g fled rupaul's
drag race season 14 had many reveals as
many queens revealed that they are trans
cornbread bosco jasmine kennedy and
winner willow pill all shared that they
were transitioning with the fandom
crediting fellow contestant carrie colby
with coming up with the nickname tranos
for her paving the way and helping
fellow contestants with any questions
and concerns they had
cat de brogle daughter of real
housewives of orange county star heather
dubrow came out as a lesbian earlier
this year and i caught up with heather
who touched on the importance of being a
supportive parent to queer youth at the
very least the people that brought you
into this world and created you
should be there for you some other
incredible coming out highlights of the
year included reese witherspoon's
daughter ava philippe sharing on
instagram that she is quote attracted to
people gender is whatever
hunger games star willow shields and
anne with an e star amy beth mcnulty
both posted on their instagram sharing
that they are bi comedian gerard
carmichael and soccer player jake
daniels both revealed that they are gay
and we can't help but stan our queen
janelle monae who came out as non-binary
and of course bachelor star becca tilly
came out as well revealing that she's
been dating singer haley kiyoko for the
last four years bringing the bachelor
nation the drama they love by announcing
it through an appearance in haley's
music video for the girls
[Music]
[Laughter]
you